hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
today i'm going to tell you guys what
happened when a hornworm got to my
tomato plant
and then i'm going to talk about
hornworms for a little while because i
kind of think they're cool and then make
sure you stay tuned until the end to see
how i recommend that you deal with
hornworms it's the way that has worked
best to keep the hornworms from damaging
the rest of my tomato plants
so
let's go ahead and get
started alrighty so here we go i've got
uh hornworms on my tomato plants what
should i do
uh it turns out that the species that uh
i found on my tomato plants is one
called manduka sexta it actually turns
into like once it's done being a
caterpillar and it metamorphoses into an
adult moth it turns into a moth that's
known as the carolina stinks moth or the
tobacco hawk moth
and so this is this is kind of how my my
journey with hornworms started i'd never
encountered hornworms before but i had
this tomato plant and it was doing
really well you can see one two three
tomatoes just from from this view alone
lots of lots of leaves and then
literally you guys the very next day
it went from looking really nice like
this to looking like this i
i like i you know i exclaimed i cried i
was so upset
every single leaf is gone every single
flower is gone the only thing that is
left is kind of the main stems and half
of a tomato right here and actually a a
hornworm was you know
eating its way through this last tomato
when i found it now the hornworms that i
have are not actually tomato hornworms
even though they're on my tomato plants
they are tobacco hornworms now these are
in the same species
excuse me not the same species the same
genus different species in the same
genus so the genus is manduka
and so there are tomato hornworms and
tomato hornworms have eight v-shaped
white markings with no borders and they
have dark blue or black horns what i
have looks like this it's actually a
manduka sex step so this is a tobacco
hormone it has seven you can count on
one two three four five six seven white
diagonal lines and you can see this kind
of dotted black border on each one
and the horn instead of being blue or
black
is red or reddish brown so
tomato hornworms tobacco hornworms
what's the difference there's not really
a whole lot i mean yes or different
species but you can treat them both the
same way so no matter which one you have
you can
take my recommendation to
keep these things from damaging your
tomato crop so tomato hornworms and
tobacco hornworms they are both happy to
eat tomato plants and tobacco plants so
the the plant itself does not give you
the species you really have to look at
the color of the horn and the markings
so the larval stage remember larval is
the caterpillar stage it actually has
five larval instar stages these are just
different stages that are separated by
molting the final instar is what i found
so i
probably had several hornworms to be
honest on that plant they were very
small
they tend to be on the underside of
leaves and so you don't necessarily
notice them
but by the time i realized there was a
problem
it really was just the next afternoon
i only saw one hornworm and it was
actually in the final
instar of those of those five and the
final instar you can see how big it is i
mean that right there is an immature
tomato
uh and you can see how large this
caterpillar is
uh and so it you know this this final
instar eats 90 of what the other four n
stars eat all together and even though i
only saw one i do wonder if there
weren't more because you know a single
adult moth can lay eggs for hundreds
of larvae and the fact that i only found
one it really does make me wonder if
there weren't more
and they had just burrowed down into the
soil already by the time i got back out
there
and so what did i do i took that single
hornworm that i found and i put it in a
terrarium
um i did offer it a few more leaves from
a sec a separate tomato plant that i had
on the other side of my house where
there were no hornworms
but it really didn't seem to be hungry
anymore and i kind of wonder what was
going on i thought is it dying like
what's what's going on because it didn't
really seem to be pupating which is
forming the pupa
but what i was actually seeing is that
the first two bullet points here the
caterpillar seeks a location burrows
underground that's known as wandering
and it did burrow into the soil of the
terrarium i had to uncover it again to
get this picture
and also in this pre-people stage the
caterpillar does shrink a little bit
which is probably why i thought it
seemed kind of ill
but it was fine and it did eventually
pupate so we got this nice pupa now
these the species is sometimes grown in
research labs for scientific research
purposes
and so in like perfect conditions in a
lab where they have 17 hours of light
and seven hours of dark kind of
mimicking those long long summer days
and short summer nights
uh and like 80 degrees fahrenheit or 20
27 degrees celsius i'm keeping those
conditions warm then this pupil stage
only lasts about 18 days before an adult
mop emerges however
when reared with
you know less light more dark lower
temperatures the pupae will enter a
period known as diapause that can last
several months and this is basically
analogous to
a pupa staying underground through fall
and winter and then emerging when spring
comes
and now
what is you know really
too bad as i was working with this
tomato plant and i was helping it regrow
you know august 9th is when i found it
just completely stripped bare no leaves
or tomatoes left i only found the one
hornworm maybe there were others that i
had missed but it did eventually regrow
and we got several leaves and many new
flowers
and then i started finding more
hornworms on september 5th i found these
these are all in probably larval in star
stage three or four
um
and then two days later i found even
smaller ones look at that look how small
they are even compared to the penny
so honestly these are probably three
different batches that first hornworm
was from the first batch
um in early august and then in early
september i had another batch and then a
few days later even another batch that
had hatched
and so i peeled all of these off you
know while wearing my gardening gloves
and i was looking at them and studying
them and my kids were looking at them
and we noticed that they had some kind
of gross traits specifically with
urination and pooping
so i'm just going to point out a few
these two yellow arrows right here you
see this liquid that's coming out of the
horn i have no idea what this is i
wondered
i would see them emit
you know three or four kind of quick
droplets at a time um and it really
wasn't clear to me whether this was like
a form of urination or whether this was
like a defense mechanism but i saw i saw
a few of them do it more than once
no idea what's going on there i tried to
google it didn't really find anything so
you know what they're doing please tell
me in the comments there was also lots
and lots of poop this is called frass
you can see some frass here you can see
this hornworm is in the process of
emitting some brass so that is their
feces now how this is probably why most
of you are watching the video uh how do
i treat this my preferred method i did
some research i decided i did not want
to use a chemical pesticide and so i
bought a biological insecticide instead
i went to
home depot or lowe's or like um some
kind of garden or like tractor supply
store
and i bought something called bt
bt biological insecticide the bt is
short for bacillus phtharingensis and
this is actually a bacterium so this is
an insect pathogen but it's only a
pathogenic to
basically very specific insects in this
case the hornworms so what i did is i
bought it as a concentrate i diluted it
something like a quarter of a teaspoon
into you know a spray bottle of water
and then i sprayed it on the leaves
and my tomato plant is doing great um
you know haven't had any more hornworm
problems since i sprayed the bt i am
going to do another biology professor
video how does bt insecticide work so um
once i get that posted you can check it
out uh and you know i just want to say
really quick that you know this this
bacterium this bacillus thuringian says
it's perfectly harmless to good insects
so it's not going to hurt your
earthworms it's not going to hurt your
pollinators like bees it's only going to
hurt insects that actually eat the
leaves
um because it's got a basically a toxin
that only activates once it's inside the
caterpillar's gut so it's only going to
kill something that's actually eating
the leaves
and only insects of course it's
perfectly harmless to humans
and so if you have a hormone problem i
recommend that you go get some bt it
will need um reapplied you know once a
week or so maybe more if it's raining a
lot but i i definitely think it's the
way to go to keep these hornworms at bay
and so this is this is where we're at
for
that first hornworm the very first one i
found that was in that final instar
stage that pupated it began pupating on
august 12th today is september 23rd so
it's 42 days later um and not showing
any activity i'm just keeping it in a
pantry now once um spring rolls around i
will pull it out and you know hopefully
we'll get an adult
moth so we'll wait and see with our
fingers crossed that's it for today i do
have some other videos
where i have tracked the metamorphosis
from that larval caterpillar sage to
adult moth for two other kinds of moths
that's the tersa stinks moths and the
harness tiger moth so if you would like
please check those out and until next
time thank you for watching biology
professor